- You know my next guest
from "One Tree Hill,"
"Grey's Anatomy," and "White Collar."
This summer she hosted "Friday
Night In With the Morgans"
on AMC with her husband,
Jeffrey Dean Morgan.
Recently she traded
the Hollywood spotlight
for a simpler life on a
farm in upstate New York.
She's written about that
in her new book, "The Rural Diaries."
It's out right now.
Let's bring her in here.
Hilarie Burton Morgan, how you doing?
- How are you?
- I am so good.
Oh my gosh, it's so
beautiful where you are!
- I'm like trying to find a place
where there's not like kids or a mailman
or like destruction anywhere.
It's just, you know how it is.
- That was literally me in Montana.
Now I'm back in LA,
but every time I had to
do my show from Montana
I was like how do I make this look,
I was like there's so much
going on here right now.
- I think there's like a
lawn mower running somewhere.
- There was always a tractor
or some loud thing happening.
Well I was just talking
to Al Roker, actually.
I was literally just talking to him,
and y'all are in the same
neck of the woods, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
I think he's up here in the Hudson Valley.
We, oh look. There's my husband now.
- I like it.
- They have no idea what we're doing.
Al does a charity with us
called Big Slick in Kansas City,
and so that's the last time we saw him.
We raised money for Children's
Mercy Hospital out there,
and we talked about being here.
The thing about being in
the Hudson Valley, though,
is that this is where you come to hide out
so you don't ever see anybody.
- That's why we went to
Montana for our vacation.
- Yeah.
- So you're living on a
farm and with your kids.
So do you put them to work?
- Oh my god. All the time, yeah.
- There's so much to get done, right?
- There's so much to get done,
and I want them to be responsible.
That was the thing we noticed in LA
was that a lot of the
kids that we would see
on the playground there weren't aware
that there's other people on the planet.
And so we want our kids to be
grounded and have a lot to do.
And so we've put 'em to work.
Whether it's like building the garden
or you can hear all the
birds in the background.
My son and-
- I can hear your rooster.
- Dude, my kids are on chicken duty.
We just-
- Yeah, we have chickens,
but I don't allow a rooster.
I'm like oh gosh.
- We've got such a bad
coyote and fox problem,
we need a boss.
- Oh, I got you.
- So he's a killer.
- That's awesome, though, that
you put your kids to work.
That's the same thing that
my husband and I were doing.
We wanted our kids to be able to actually,
because I grew up in the
countryside and so did he.
So is it true that you
not only write books,
shoot a talk show, run a farm,
but you're also helping
out local hospitals?
- So many of our good friends
here in the Hudson Valley
are members of the medical field.
Whether it's like doctors
or nurses or EMTs.
And so the immediacy
of helping all of them
was really important.
So we started sewing masks right away,
encouraging other people to sew masks.
A lot of the moms, it's
like all soccer moms.
We all got together and
started raising money
to feed all the medical workers
at our COVID testing facility.
So now that same group of people,
we're taking all that energy
we had for the pandemic,
and we're putting it towards
our schoolteachers now.
Because we have no idea
what school is gonna
look like in the fall,
and our teachers can't afford crayons
and paper and books
and stuff for the kids,
let alone PPE for
everybody to make it safe.
So, we're trying to-
- Even thinking about like
a lot of us with kids,
our kids, they might still be home.
- Yeah.
- And a lot of parents
don't have access to all those supplies.
- Not every kid has a computer or an iPad.
- But your new book is
about your life up there,
and I think that it's really cool.
So what inspired you to do it?
Was it because basically
you had that other lifestyle
and you wanted it slowed down a bit?
- Yeah, I mean you know.
We grew up, and it was
like, "You're on TV!"
And you have to grow up in
front of a lot of people,
and you've gotta project
this certain image.
And so when I kind of took
off working to be a mom,
I didn't do social media.
I didn't engage in any of that.
And I was encouraged to join social media,
and what I saw was just kinda unattainable
and super glamorous.
And it made me feel bad.
I didn't like when I felt
like I was missing out
or that I wasn't living
up to some expectation.
So I started posting just
really like stripped down,
here's the farm kinda posts,
and people responded to it.
And so I wanted to write a love letter
to our community and our lifestyle
that glamorized the small,
beautiful, noble lives
that take place when nobody's looking.
Not every has to be on a yacht.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah, well what kind of
animals do you have on the farm?
- Well I've got, Jeffrey has
corralled our new baby chicken.
Can you say hi?
- Oh, hi! What's up?
- Hey, how are ya?
Nice to see ya.
- Oh my gosh! So cute!
And I know you have chickens
and ducks like that.
But what else do you have?
- This is the donkey whisperer.
He spends all day brushing
the donkeys in the field.
Here, do you wanna sit down?
Cuddle up, Dad.
We've got alpaca.
We've got a lot of mini
donkeys we've rescued,
Jack and Diane.
- Highland cattle, and then
every spring we take in cows
from the local dairy farm that we raise,
yearlings with their moms.
- Yeah, so a cow/calf operation.
Okay, cool. That's cool.
- We get calls all the time.
People are like, "Oh,
this farm is closing down.
Will you take our animals."
So even if we can't take them,
we try to hook them up
with other people who can.
- No, that's so hilarious.
That happened to me in Texas.
I had a rescue ranch,
and like literally people were
just dropping animals out.
And I was like, "Okay, there comes a point
to where we won't be able
to get to all of them."
So that does happen.
- It's just us.
- Yeah.
It was me and my sister and her family,
and I was like, "People don't work here."
- No!
- It's just us holding it down.
So I would just wanna say, everybody,
obviously Jeffrey Dean Morgan,
he's now involved in the
interview. And I'm such a big fan.
I love "The Walking Dead"
so I'm just gonna say that shout out.
- Thank you.
(voice breaks up)
- Thank you for hanging out with us.
So Hilarie told us how special
your community is up there.
What's your favorite part about it?
She told us why she kinda
liked living up there
and out of the limelight.
I love it as well, obviously.
We have a place in Montana.
But I wanna know why you
like that kind of life
but also I heard you owned a candy shop.
Do you still own a candy shop?
- We do.
I think just getting out
of Los Angeles for us,
it was so needed, I think,
just for our well-being.
And then having kids, and it started out
with obviously just the one, Gus.
And we thought that this kind of lifestyle
was very conducive to raising a good kid.
And so far, so good.
- He's good for now!
- He's good. He's alive, he's breathing.
- Yeah, yeah.
He's pretty good.
And George is a real animal
whisperer too, it turns out.
Her and I are the, we love our animals.
- Gus and I are the gardeners.
They're the animal people.
- Yeah, she spends a lot of
time in the chicken coops.
She loves the chickens.
She loves all the animals,
but she loves the chickens.
Like every night it's a thing.
She has to have her chicken and duck time.
- That's so cool, too,
to have both worlds.
- Thank you guys so much
for hanging out with us!
I love your beautiful farm!
- Thank you for having us!
- Y'all be sure to pick
up Hilarie's new book,
"The Rural Diaries."
Rural is hard for me to say.